je ne comprends pas je vois je vois pas
pourquoi ils peuvent l'être les juifs le
sont les protestants leçon je vois pas
pourquoi compris vrai un homme du désir
d'aimer de la chair et autres choses qui
peuvent approfondir le désir de vivre à
deux
et encore mieux en communion quoi donc
vous êtes pour le mariage des prêtres
entre bien c'est entre eux
le mariage ne prétend t non alors là
l'eau non bravo vous pensez qu'il est
mieux qu'il continue de se cacher que
les prêtres se fâche se cache cache leur
amour moi je préfère oui si je
connaissais un prêt qui ont qui était un
peu plus rapprochée que les autres mais
j'avais quoi j'avais 12 ans et tripoter
un petit peu par un prêtre d'éléments
ouais ouais mais bon c'est on est ouest
ouais mais non mais c'est contradictoire
à vocation on avait pensé au mariage ils
cette époque avec lui allons y amoureux
un peu lâche
non c'était comme un père j'ai passé ma
mais non on va faire un petit peu assez
ce que tu peux tu pour aucun mariage
quels qu'ils soient
pourquoi pensez pas
vous êtes pour l'union libre en ce qui
concerne les prêtres ah oui chacun fait
ce qui lui plaît et lorsqu ils s'aiment
au couteau raconte les histoires de huit
mois comment le mariage des prêtres
entre eux homayoun nom de monseigneur
qui en pince pour un autre monseigneur
même vous avez déjà eu une relation leur
relation sexuelle avec un prêtre et les
soeurs entre l appareil
il était curé et les soeurs c'est ça
doit se faire sur 20 ans contre khartoum
et les curés les bergers allemands les
cours est sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu